[Musique]
mes chers compatriotes après
consultation du premier ministre du
président du sénat du président de
l'assemblée nationale
j'ai décidé de dissoudre l'assemblée
nationale
le décret de dissolution et le décret
fixant les dates des élections
législatives au 25 mai au 1er juin
seront publiés demain matin pourquoi au
risque de vous surprendre
me suis résolu à user maintenant du
pouvoir que me confère l'article 12 de
la constitution pour abréger le mandat
d'une assemblée que j'ai tenu à
conserver en 1995 dont la majorité a
soutenu loyalement le gouvernement une
assemblée qui a contribué à définir les
lignes de force d'une france moderne et
compétitive et à laquelle je tiens à
rendre hommage
aujourd'hui je considère en conscience
que l'intérêt du pays commande
d'anticiper les élections j'ai acquis la
conviction qu'il faut redonner la parole
à notre peuple afin qu'il se prononce
clairement sur l'ampleur et sur le
rythme des changements à conduire
pendant les cinq prochaines années pour
aborder cette nouvelle étape nous avons
besoin d'une majorité ressourcer et
disposant du temps nécessaire à l'action
nous avons engagés ensemble mais fort
considère des réformes de fond sont en
cours la protection sociale les armes et
le service national d'enseignement
supérieur la fiscalité le secteur public
après un long laisser-aller dont nous
payons toujours le prix l'assainissement
de nos finances a été entrepris grâce à
chacun d'entre vous nous avons ainsi
recréer les conditions de la croissance
cette politique commence à donner des
résultats mais ils ne sont pas
suffisants ce n'est donc pas le moment
de marquer une pause
notre économie nos entreprises l'emploi
le peuvent à temps
il faut au contraire damon aller plus
loin sur le chemin des changements il
faut que l'action politique monte en
puissance pendant les cinq années qui
viennent pour réussir la france a besoin
d'un nouvel élan
cet élan ne peut être donnée que par
l'adhésion clairement exprimée du peuple
français mes chers compatriotes le
moment est venu de vous prononcer en
sang le nous devons réformer en
profondeur l'état afin de permettre une
baisse de la dépense publique
seule façon d'alléger les impôts et les
charges qui pèsent trop lourdement sur
vous et qui trop souvent vous démotive
la baisse des impôts c'est un choix
exigeant mais c'est un choix majeur que
je fais parce que c'est le choix de
l'avenir ensemble nous devons 11
encourager plus fortement qu'on le fait
les créations d'entreprises et des
initiatives locales qui font notre
richesse
nous devons faire évoluer les
comportements qui font obstacle à
l'emploi il faut partout développer le
dialogue et la concertation pour trouver
de nouvelles réponses au chômage
ensemble nous devons prendre toutes les
mesures qui s'imposent afin que notre
système éducatif s'adapte aux exigences
de l'entrée des jeunes dans la vie
active
nous devons poursuivre la nécessaire
adaptation de notre protection sociale
dont je suis et donc je resterai le
garant nous devons réformer notre
justice et la rendre plus indépendante
mais aussi plus rapide et plus proche
vous le voyez il s'agit de choix
déterminant pour chacun d'entre eux et
ses choix requiert exigent votre
adhésion
et puis il y à l'europe elle impose
parfois des contraintes c'est vrai mais
ne l'oublions jamais depuis un demi
siècle pour nos vieilles nations qui se
sont tant combattu l'europe c'est la
paix aujourd'hui dans un monde qui
s'organise et se transforme toujours
plus vite
l'europe nous apportera un supplément de
prospérité et de sécurité
tout simplement parce que l'europe c'est
l'union et que l'union fait la force
or d'importantes décisions seront prises
au cours des tout prochains mois
le passage à la monnaie unique
indispensable si nous voulons nous
affirmer comme une grande puissance
économique et politique avec un euro à
l'égal du dollar et du yen
la réforme des institutions européennes
que nous voulons plus démocratique plus
équilibrée plus efficace l'élargissement
de l'union au jeune démocratie qui
appartiennent à la famille européenne et
qui formeront avec nous
la grande roue la réforme de l'alliance
atlantique qui doit permettre aux
européens de mieux assumer la
responsabilité de leur sécurité dans un
nouveau partage avec les américains
c'est sûr
et sûrement ce qui me tient le plus à
coeur
une union européenne au service d un
modèle social vivent un front commun
contre les fléaux qui menacent nos
sociétés
le chômage et l'exclusion bien sûr mais
aussi l'exploitation des enfants
la drogue l'argent sale le terrorise
tout cela a donné lieu à des
négociations difficiles pour aborder ces
échéances en position de force pour
construire une europe respectueuse du
génie des nations qui la composent est
capable de rivaliser avec les grands
ensembles mondiaux votre adhésion et
votre soutien sont essentiels enfin mes
chers compatriotes nous partageons des
valeurs qui fondent notre communauté
nationale et qu'il donne à la france son
destin singulier
or les esprits sont troublés des
principes essentiels ont été mis en
cause le respect dû à chaque homme la
tolérance la solidarité la plus
élémentaire des appels à la haine ont
été lancés et des boucs émissaires
désignés
ensemble nous devons réaffirmer nos
valeurs et les repères civiques et
moraux qui sont les nôtres
ensemble nous devons dire clairement
dans quelle société nous voulons vivre
des réponses aux grandes questions qui
se posent aujourd'hui ne se trouve ni
dans le repli sur nous mêmes ni dans
l'exploitation des pères et des
ignorances les réponses ne se trouve pas
non plus dans un laisser faire laisser
aller contraire à notre culture
et à nos traditions sociales les
réponses ne se trouve pas davantage dans
des solutions archaïque fondée sur le
toujours plus dé talent toujours plus de
dépenses le toujours plus d'impôts c'est
un autre chemin que je vous propose de
suivre ce que je vous propose c'est
l'idéal de notre république des droits
farouchement défendu et d'abord le droit
à la dignité et à la protection pour
chaque homme chaque femme chaque enfant
mes devoirs et des responsabilités
assumées qui correspondent à ses droits
une cohésion sociale renforcée c'est la
défense de l'ordre républicain
c'est une société apaisée décrispés qui
anticipe mieux les problèmes et qu'ils
les surmonte par le dialogue et la
concertation
c'est une morale politique retrouvée
avec des dirigeants qui donne l'exemple
c'est une vie politique moderniser
donnant toute leur place aux femmes et
où les élus se consacre pleinement à
leurs fonctions
c'est une france laïque respectueuse des
croyances de chacun
voilà pourquoi mes chers compatriotes je
vous demande de donner à la france une
majorité qui aura la force et la durée
nécessaire pour relever les défis
d'aujourd'hui
rien n'est facile mais nous devons
choisir la bonne voire celle qui
concilie la justice la solidarité et la
modernité
nous sommes à moins de 1000 jour de l'an
de ville je veux que nous exprimions
sans tarder notre volonté commune
d'entrée dans le troisième millénaire
avec confiance et avec enthousiasme
mes chers compatriotes je vous remercie
pas
[Musique]